près de 40 % d'augmentation sur le bois
la ferraille le ciment et pour certaines
pièces elles peuvent atteindre les 100%
première raison il devient de plus en
plus difficile de trouver des containers
dans le monde et donc le coût du
transport entre l'europe et les antilles
a augmenté deuxième raison pour faire
ces matériaux il faut de l'électricité
et le coût de l'énergie a lui aussi
augmenté dans le monde conséquence
un si gros problème
pour cent d'augmentation depuis deux ans
et ça change tout le bas du 2 bat de vie
ça sent complètement le baht de vie et
on a du mal à faire comprendre nos
clients au bignon final le prix que
qu'on va appliquer maintenant c'est
terrible c'est à dire que l'affairé a
pris 40 % en deux ans oui depuis le
début de la pandémie a aujourd'hui on a
40% d'augmentation
et donc c'est considérable et sur
d'autres produits on a t on atteint des
sommets si les prix augmentent trop au
moment donné c'est le client final qui
va le ressentir et donc il y aura moins
de chantiers donc on n'a pas intérêt à
ce que ça augmente trop voilà on a
intérêt au contraire revenir sur des
niveaux corrects de prix une stabilité
des prix pour que justement l'écosystème
du btp en martinique puisse fonctionner
normalement et avec cette augmentation
des matériaux c'est tout le btp qui
risque d'être en crise
de plus les professionnels ne savent pas
quand s'arrêtera cette flambée des prix
difficile non pour eux pour ceux qui
veulent construire de se lancer dans de
nouveaux projets